How's it going everyone and welcome back
to another video. In this video we are
going to be talking about targets within
the fractal model. Let's get into the
PDF.
So when determining targets within the
fractal model, it's actually quite
simple. What you are going to do is
whatever time frame you are on for entry
and whatever higher time frame you are
referencing, you're just going to focus
on the higher time frame. By looking at
the higher time frame candles, that is
how you are going to get relevant levels
for targets. So you can see here, we
have a candle two closure, candle three
looking to expand. What is our target?
Well, it's just going to be these
previous candles lows. So what does that
actually look like? Here you can see
with a candle two closure or a candle
three closure, what are our targets?
Well, here you can see candle one's high
as well as the previous candles high as
well as previous candles highs that are
not shown on this diagram. Similar here
on the bearish setup, previous candles
lows. So candle one low and the previous
lows here.
Now, what is the goal of using higher
time frame targets? Well, this is
telling you where you can hold your
trade to. So for example here, if I was
on the hourly and five minute fractal
model here, here I have an hourly candle
two closure. We had our five minute
change in the state of delivery inside
this wick and looking to trade this
candle three continuation higher. We get
our intra candle change in the state of
delivery and we can be looking for price
to trade higher here. Where to? Well, we
can look on this time frame and see the
targets. We have a target here as well
as a target here. Now that is a great
trade alone, but what can we do if we
align these targets together or look up
to a higher time frame? Here you can see
with the daily candle shown here on the
left, we're actually in a candle three
expansion on the daily. So we can use
that candle one target or the previous
candles targets to look for this trade
to extend to. This allows me to take a
trade looking for I initial or
short-term targets, but then hold
runners to these higher time frame
objectives. This is how you get better
RR out of the same trade. So, let's go
into TradingView and go over a few
examples of this.
So, here we are in our first example,
and what do we have? We have a candle
two closure here on the higher time
frame. And that is also paired with an
hourly change in the state of delivery.
Since we're on the daily, we will be
using the hourly according to the time
frame alignment that I use. So, if we're
looking for a target on this move lower
here, right? Looking for this candle
three to expand lower, what can we look
for? We can just mark out our previous
lows, right? Which would be this low
down here, as well as this low down
here.
So, applying those to the lower time
frame, what do we have? We have this low
right here, and then this low right
here.
Now, I can go ahead and check this by
turning on my indicator,
turning it back on. Did we mark out the
correct targets? And we did, right? So,
if we look, we're looking for this
previous low and this previous low as
targets. And so, let's see what happens.
We'll go ahead and remove the drawings
and let this play out. You can see,
price makes a high,
expands lower, it hits its first target.
Do we get a retracement or a reversal?
No, we get a consolidation, which is a
continuation signature, and we trade
lower. So, just to review, make your
targets super simple. If you're on an
intraday time frame or using the hourly
chart, focus on those previous days
highs and lows. So, here on the daily
and hourly chart, I'm going to be
looking at those previous days highs or
lows. In a bearish model, it will be
lows. We mark out our previous lows, and
that will be our target for this move
lower.
So, here we are in another example. We
have expansion down, taking out some
lows, and expansion back up. So, we
could be looking for this to trade
higher. What do we have? We have a
candle to closure at a point of
interest. So, we have this fair value
gap here. Price has taken out the low
and closed back above it. So, we could
be looking for this to trade higher.
Now, before we go to the lower time
frame, what would be our targets here?
Well, we know if we go to the lower time
frame, we're going to be using the
higher time frames for our targets. So,
we have this high here. Now, why am I
not making out with this previous high?
Well, it already got taken out here. If
we would have had this high higher up,
well, then we could have marked it out
as another target. But, since it's
already taken out, we just have this
level here.
Now, that is what we have for our
short-term targets. Our higher time
frame targets can also be our previous
highs. So, you can see these highs over
here.
Why would I mark those out? Well, on a
higher time frame, if we go to the
weekly from the daily here, that's going
to be a swing low.
And then that will be our previous
highs. So, we're always going to be
focused on swing highs and lows or
previous candles highs and lows as
targets. We go down to the hourly chart
here. And zooming in here, you can see
it marks out our previous high, or this
candle one high in this case, as our
target.
As we let this play ahead, you can see
we hit our target. And if we go through
this target, then we can go look for us
to trade to what? Those weekly targets,
right? Cuz it is a fractal concept. You
can trade on multiple different time
frames. We go down to the weekly, you
can see the swing point here on the
weekly. And then when it reverses, where
is the targets? That swing high. Right?
So, we're always focused on swing highs
and swing lows in the market. So, we can
go for another example. Right here.
We have a swing low forming right here.
What is going to be our target? Our
swing high or right here.
So, if we go down to something like the
4-hour time frame here, you can see down
here on the 4-hour time frame, that low
that we marked out, and then our
previous high as a target. And then once
again, it's very simple. It's just going
to be a reference to the higher time
frame using time frame alignment, and
that swing high will be your target. So,
if we're going to see this trade higher,
where do we want to see it go? To its
target.
And there you can see, we go and hit our
target. Let's get into another example.
So, here we are on the daily, and let's
go over a few examples of just finding
swing points and their targets.
So, what do we notice here? We have a
candle three closure, cuz candle two
didn't close back above this level, but
then candle three engulfed it. So, where
would be the target on this? Well, we
find candle two's low. This is where we
are trading away from. What is to the
left, and we mark out the highs. So,
that is our target for this move.
Right? And we hit that. Now, we can wait
for a new swing point. We don't have
anything, we just have a consolidation.
We trade higher. Here we have a new
swing point. What's going to be our
target on this? Well, candle two. This
is where we are trading away from.
What are we looking to trade towards?
Well, these are going to be our targets,
our previous lows. That's our candle
one, and then our previous low, and then
you can continue to mark out previous
lows.
Right? Those are all going to be
targets, especially equal lows like
that. So, that all gets taken. We
retrace back up. There's no valid
fractal formation in here. Here we get
another candle two closure. Where would
be the target on this one? Well, candle
one. We've already taken out the low,
right? But, we have these previous lows
as targets. So, you guys see what's
going on here? Every time we have a
valid swing point, we just look to the
previous candles, mark out their high or
their low, and that's the target. So,
what do we notice here? We run out this
whole range. We have a candle two
closure. So, what is going to be our
targets on this one? And pause the video
if you have to, and practice marking it
out. But, we have our previous highs,
right? That's a previous high. This is a
previous high. This is a previous high.
Now, why am I not marking out this high
here? Well, it's already been taken out.
So, I'm focusing on those highs that
haven't been taken out. So, now we have
these targets for the move up. Let's see
what happens.
And there we take out all those targets.
So, once again,
keep your targets very simple. Whatever
time frame you are trading, if you're
trading intraday, I like to focus on the
daily chart. But, whatever the higher
time frame reference is, those are going
to be your targets. Focus on those
previous highs and lows.
So, let's take a look at this example
here. What do we have? We have price
reaching into a fair value gap over
here. A candle two closure. So, where
would be the targets in this move lower?
Our previous lows, right? And those are
equal lows, which form a fair value gap.
So, that's a nice target. Here, we form
a new swing. What becomes the target
there? Right here and right here.
Right? And we don't go reach up to this
final target, and that's fine. We don't
expect it to do that all in one day.
That's too much daily range. We want to
see how it closes. It closes really weak
right here, forming a new candle two.
So, then what becomes our target for
this move?
We would expect to reach for this low.
Now, what is the one point in which case
we don't need to see price reach for
this target? When there's SMT or a
correlated asset takes out this low.
So, if we take a look at silver here,
because we're on gold, you can see
silver took out this target. So, that
allows us to say that the target has
been hit or has an SMT. So, cleaning up
the drawings once again, with this move
higher, backed with SMT, what are we
looking for or what are we looking to
target? The previous highs.
So, we can mark out those highs there as
targets and go down to the lower time
frame. So, down here on the lower time
frame, we can go ahead and remove the
drawings and you can see those targets
will remain there because my indicator
is going to go ahead and mark those out
for us. So, let's see what happens now.
We want to wait for this wick to form
intraday.
And what do we have? We have price open,
low, taking out all this consolidation
into this gap. This protected swing
right here is holding that level. And
then we have a little consolidation and
sweep with a candle two closure. So,
zooming in here, what would be our
target on our lower timeframe fractal
here? And this is what I'm talking about
when I'm combining or aligning
timeframes together. We have this candle
two here. So, we have candle one high.
That would be a short-term target. But
what is our higher timeframe targets? Up
here, right? So, let's go ahead and mark
those out and then we'll go to the lower
timeframe.
So, marking those out, let's go down to
the five-minute timeframe. So, down here
on the five-minute timeframe, we can go
ahead and remove these drawings cuz the
indicator will mark it out. And we're a
bit late to this, but what do we have?
We have a protected swing or a
continuation that forms right here in
candle three,
which could have been our entry, right?
Now, on this entry here, we'd be wanting
to get to our to this short-term target,
right? So, we could either adjust the
entry a little to get that two hour, or
what can we do? We can look for these
targets above here or those higher
timeframe targets we marked out. And
this is how you get really high risk
reward moves is when you can take off a
portion of your position at your
short-term target and then hold a runner
to see if it can go to our higher
timeframe target. Let's see what happens
here.
Here you can see candle four, we go and
hit our short-term target. So, this is
where I could take profit on this
intraday move and then I could hold
runners to see if what? If we did get a
trend and we can reach towards those
higher timeframe targets. So, letting
this go,
you can see price does reach up to those
higher time frame targets. So, if I was
going to let a runner go, this is where
I can get a very nice move on a runner.
Now, why and how does this work? Well,
let's go back to our hourly time frame.
If you are catching a lower time frame
fractal inside a higher time frame
fractal, and this is what I'm talking
about when I'm saying trading C3 inside
a C3, this is candle three on the daily
time frame. We are looking for this to
expand. If I align that with a candle
three on the lower time frame, looking
for that to expand, I can catch that
move intraday, and then hold to see if
this move goes to the higher time frame
targets. And here you can see it did.
So, if we go back to the lower time
frame here and rewind,
you can see that's where you can get
really good risk to reward trades
because this runner is going to go hit,
in this case, 1 to 11 or even 1 to 16,
which is really great risk to reward for
a runner. So, going back out to the
hourly time frame here, let's see what
happens.
Because what is our higher time frame
target? Right there. So, going back to
our daily chart where it all started,
what do we have? We have a swing point.
And why was this our target? Because
that is our candle one high as well as
our previous highs.
So, I hope you found this video helpful.
If you did, please consider liking and
subscribing, and go check this out for
yourself in your own charts. See if you
can practice finding targets on your
chart. I'll see you guys next week. Have
a good one.
If you are looking for a way to work
more closely with me and get more
one-on-one support within your trading,
you can click the link below. We have a
waitlist for our program, so you can
join and I will let you know when we
have new openings.